beyonce stephanie's singing in
tishomingo
[Music]
blake shelton and gwen stefani are
hitting the stage for the first time as
a married couple
and gwen's first time as mrs shelton
it's one of those once in a lifetime you
know moments on thursday the newlyweds
hit up all red
a bar blake owns in oklahoma for an
intimate performance
[Music]
the low-key duet had fans totally hyped
but what really caught everyone's
attention
is how gwen reacted to blake's
introduction beyonce stephanie's singing
what planet is
[Applause]
[Music]
yep you heard her gwen shelton
[Music]
the couple then kicked off their
surprise performance singing
several of their hits including gwen
singing her band no doubts
don't speak and like a true
perfectionist she directed the band to
make sure she could sing it
just right
[Applause]
[Music]
of course once everything was right the
grammy winner did not disappoint as her
new hubby supported her while playing
guitar in the background
[Music]
yes blake and gwen tied the knot earlier
this month in a very
intimate ceremony also in oklahoma
officiated by their pal
and host of the voice carson daly and
back in april gwen told seth meyers
that a small wedding was really all she
ever wanted
very simple really simple the guest list
will not have a lot of musicians it's
gonna be like my mom
and my dad like just literally gonna be
just
family and um we are looking forward to
that though it's gonna be fun we're
gonna make it really fun but it's not
gonna be a big like
you know it's not like the queen and
king are getting married
a source told et at the time it was
absolutely a picture-perfect intimate
wedding with family
everyone at the wedding was so thrilled
to see gwen and blake finally get
married
the couple married six years after
unexpectedly finding love while working
as dueling coaches on the voice
and ever since the pair has never been
shy about their love for one another
i think somebody that can make you laugh
constantly
is very sexy and somebody that
is let's see humble
kind down to earth selfless
talented on the top of their game
should i keep going both of our lives
have basically fallen
completely apart and uh and little did
we know it happened to both of us
at the same time and uh we bonded over
that
and then you know it's so somewhere in
in that
you know that time of of just
you know darkness was this ended up
being
the greatest moment of my life you know
so it's just it's amazing it truly is
another source told et at the time
they've been so careful because they've
had their hearts broken
and this wedding made everyone feel like
dreams do really come true
they have both been through a lot and
deserve to find each other they were
meant to be a couple in
every way congrats to blake and gwen
shelton